but that neither pom stealing on
accident is still stealing movie rips
off Raiders and inspires the Brendan
Fraser mummy movies all in one
establishing shot to say nothing of the
fella after unearthing this ancient
artifact these presumably skilled
archaeologists decide that the best
course of action is to pull this thing
upright potentially damaging it even
though there's no indication that it's
supposed to be that way unless there's a
hieroglyphic on the side that says this
side up or something hardest game of
horseshoes ever and nothing of
importance happened with the strange
alien ring door for 75 years this is the
most heavily attended lecture about the
Egyptian pyramids in the history of ever
this is a friend of dude with some wacky
new theories no way the Hall is packed
like a screen junkies panel at Comic Con
Colonel vise discovered quorum ins
inscriptions of Khufu's name within the
pyramid
well his discovery was a fraud after
some quick googling I discovered there
some controversy around vises discovery
but it seems highly unlikely that he
forged the Khufu cartouche yet no one in
the room challenges Daniels claim that
this is a frog even though most
historians and Egyptologists think vises
discoveries are authentic I don't have
any idea who built them apparently
saying I don't know in a lecture about
the pyramids is a huge no-no
because he said plenty of equally crazy
stuff before this yet that statement is
what prompted everyone to leave someone
wants to speak with you Oh awesome
could you be a little more vague ancient
Egyptian hit a goose I have never heard
anyone used that pronunciation in my
life
opening any kind of paperwork in that
kind of downpour would leave the
paperwork in tatters in a matter of
seconds movie so King I know he's
curious but he's a scientist he's too
smart to look at this in a downpour of
noah level rainfall hey we need a way to
show this former soldiers despondent
i've got it have him looking at
childhood photos and zoning out while
literally stroking a potential suicide
gun in his hand
brilliant we're here to inform you that
you've been reactivated despite your
obvious mental health issues which
apparently no one knows about or which
are being overlooked for some reason but
which are still obvious and honestly
kind of frightening how to get like that
his kid dad accidentally shot himself
did that not come up before they were
sent to fetch him out
this happens when I travel only dopey
nerds have allergies hello hi Gary - how
are you Richard kind isn't in a Pixar
movie in this movie - of the three males
in the shot are wearing sweater shirt
combos worthy of Tim Allen in the Santa
Clause circuit roll credits my report
says ten thousand you know you're a
workaholic when getting called back to
work is the only thing that can snap you
out of a deep depression caused by your
son accidentally killing himself
nothing hadn't occurred for the next two
weeks Daniel plays back his recorded
notes so we the audience can get up to
speed on what he's accomplished in the
last two weeks the answer is nothing
he doesn't dump out the three ounces of
remaining coffee in the pot before
filling it with water to make a new pot
I mean the hell do you even coffee
random perfectly time newspaper article
that inspires the protagonist ex machina
asking for permission rather than
forgiveness
I guess this looks the same but there
are several major differences that give
me reasonable doubt we could have at
least made the hieroglyphic version have
the same general points that the
constellation has brought Master
overloaded the nerd character with an
orgy of evidence level of underarm
blueprints for the scene remember when
this asshole owns despond it and ready
to kill himself like two weeks ago this
movie ever going to address that
well what device
show it you brought in an expert to help
you decipher the markings but didn't
show him everything the kind of logic
are you following Daniel draws on the
monitor with permanent marker instead of
just saying hey I think this is the
right symbol I was in front of us the
whole time I don't think Jackson is a
genius so much as Myers is really really
bad at his job also if they knew six
symbols already why didn't they just try
the combination with each symbol until
the thing turned on is it like an iPhone
it will erase the wormhole if you enter
the combination wrong more than three
times also they go from he identified
the symbol to activate the fucker with
not only zero questions or objections
but also zero seconds of time my father
founded 1928 and so he owned it but he
was stupid so he put it in storage
discount Fisher Stevens and discount
Summer Glau cross with Nancy Travis here
are in shock oh I just made a Fisher
Stevens joke and now the boobies gonna
give me a discount Johnny Five even if
this galaxy did exist there would be no
way they would be able to get any
information from a device in this galaxy
that is on the other side of the
universe seconds after they set a probe
there based on this new information I
don't see how we can do that I could do
that why are they also taken aback by
this this guy just cracked the code on
the earth portal in two weeks if they
seem baffled that he would be able to do
basically the same thing from the other
side somehow in 1994 Fifth Avenue candy
bars had the marketing budget for
product placement in a late summer early
fall blockbuster back up storage
their power ah having seen this whole
movie I know for a fact this chick is
just reciting gibberish for the sake of
creating movie excitement Stargate makes
easy Mack sounds when people step into
it movie wants this to be a space portal
gate but background dialogue about
Molecular deconstruction makes me view
it as more of a Star Trek transporter
overall makes me realize this movies
writers don't care or know much about
science
Daniel is wasting precious time by
playing with the Stargate and also
bloating the movies around time also no
one wants to take the time to describe
what this feels like is it wet ticklish
warm fuzzy tingly I guess we'll never
know they all decide to use flares
because flashlights are just too
practical
I guess we needed a solid for
establishing shots of this structure
also I'm not entirely sure this isn't
the temple of gozer from ghostbusters 3
Bruce Almighty moons in one shop that
has to be a record this is a replica of
the Great Pyramid of Giza isn't the
whole point that the Great Pyramid of
Giza is a replica of this your job here
is to realign the Stargate can you do
that or not I can't and this is why they
should have discussed it a little
further before the general immediately
added Daniel to the team it just turn on
the gate from the other side Oh oh it
doesn't work that way you see if you
don't turn it on from here we're screwed
but why though does the Stargate only
work in the direction where it's
activated
Danya doesn't immediately notice these
footprints after cresting the sand dune
the first alien we see use a buffalo
that looks like James looked it it's
okay it's okay
Jackson teleported to another dimension
but still has complete confidence he can
approach control and tame this planet's
version of a woolly hippo you're not
even offering it anything just an open
hand of gentrification this wookie
mammoth is running way too fast for any
humans to keep up with him but keep up
with him they do character gets licked
awake by gross animal cliche based on
the size of this dune I'm not entirely
sure he could see anything that would
have prompted him to take a closer look
he's highly trained military
professionals stand in plain view of
these potentially hostile alien
creatures so that is a scary alien
ritual say let's walk right towards it
hi even though these human aliens have
similar structures to our ancient
Egyptians Daniel doesn't try to speak to
them in ancient Egyptian instead he just
says hi in English just stares blankly
Wow
well handshaking is a pretty American
thing even multiple cultures on our own
planet don't do the handshake
so some alien kid yeah he's gonna react
like you just ordered his castration
because on this planet they probably do
things differently you idiots
bio-cop now I can't make it out in order
to help me feel what the main characters
are feeling movie offers up zero
captions for this man's comment leading
me to believe he's saying Darmok and
Jalad at Tanagra they all drink this
without having any idea what it is for
all they know it's antifreeze and
they're drinking from mini bedpans
I took some readings on what they're
mining back there this is the only
soldier who's bothering to actually do
his job even though there were a bunch
of tents at the last location our
civilization is way the far away so
let's walk for a montage I mean a bit
this alien shit falls for James Spader
faster than you can say alien libidos
are swift this was covered up so we
could have this dramatic reveal that
could also have been accomplished by a
simple camera tilt also is it just me or
is this rejoice in the sandstorm band
playing the beat for my milkshake brings
all the boys to the art I don't think we
should need any food here but you will
gladly accept their water you said
chicken Wow Wow
what the hell's going on an alien planet
after passing through a magical Stargate
and you stop enough earth focus to ask a
question like this couldn't literally
anything be going on it was strange to
you right now but still possibly
explainable by the whole not earth
planet thing no one will be seated
during the weird society worships James
Spader like the Ewoks worship c-3po see
it really worked out that these aliens
look exactly like humans and the ruler
guy's daughter is hot or this would have
been really awkward Daniel I'm Daniel
are we really having a me Tarzan you
Jane moment right now
this interspecies couple that can only
communicate via dirt drawings is
communicating better after 10 minutes
than most married couples I know
communicate after 10 years going through
the Stargate must erase any military
training because these guys clearly
don't know how to look around with their
weapons drawn anymore this movie skirt
Russell is basically half Snake Plissken
and half Todd 3 4 6 5 from soldier it
took little to no time for one of the
humans to teach one of the aliens one of
our terrible habits I cubed he's going
to be so disappointed when it runs out
of fluid no dangerous I almost forgot
that alien kid touching his gun hits
incredibly close to home because Jackson
shot himself because no one ever talks
about it at this point I have to mention
I haven't had one goddamn macgyver
sighting in this entire movie and that's
worth us in god dammit math not to
nothing we do many minutes of language
lessons Batmobile Faye wrote two movie
places undo value on a Zippo lighter
just like out of sight the oceans movies
Reservoir Dogs die hard
The Weeknd's hairstyle suddenly makes
sense to me just when you relax too
violently discounters cristo attempts to
invade the store he came to a world rich
with life wall of hieroglyphics on this
alien planet explains in great detail
the entire backstory of the movie now he
apparently found a young boy man his
interpretive powers increased tenfold
after arriving on this alien planet
where he looked into already kind of
knowing their base language versus
Evanson it's worn off because it would
just be too easy for it to be sitting
there in pristine condition like
everything else in this cave
can someone teach the colonel and the
rest of his crew while we're at it how
to properly hold their guns well this
isn't fair these alien creatures have
these Egyptian cattle prods all the
Earthlings have are these machine guns
stay right here and shoot anything that
comes down that ramp oh good I was
starting to worry they weren't familiar
with the concept of shooting down
Jackson yeah go ahead and put it down
your chance to shoot was a good 30
seconds ago and you ruined it
that's a bomb isn't it that's what you
were looking for what the hell are you
thinking
would you come in for Daniel doesn't ask
him three more questions all in
succession that he cannot answer
really dude you're not gonna try and at
least shoot some of these other henchmen
headed your way
this guy simply forgot how to military
strings hmm
once again information that could have
been useful to me yesterday um young
pong rah needs to watch some of our Bond
films so he'll know that revealing your
evil plan to the hero is never a good
idea you know what I can see me full
horror oh no no that still doesn't
answer the question of why also ancient
Egypt was badass and all but it was by
no means the genesis of every single
world civilization and that's why you
don't give a weapon to a prisoner it's
pretty great that everyone on this
planet wears flowy brown sheets it makes
it super easy to hide anyone holy these
alien gods are terrible shots and these
alien humans are terrible at running
away no one is doing well right now
take these guns away lieutenant before
they hurt themselves
quick reminder Jackson accidentally
killed himself with a gun don't worry I
forgot about it too for what to do what
more the same I guess they're only like
10 bad guys in this movie and thousands
of good guys I think we need to get this
bin out of shape over having the fight
my orders were simple track down signs
of any possible danger if I found any
blow of the Stargate the military since
I'm on a suicide mission for no reason
besides giving the movie a reason to
have a bomb creating this final conflict
also do we really need an atomic bomb to
blow up the Stargate couple of sticks of
dynamite would probably do the trick or
even a really good sledgehammer
oh he has a Nintendo Power glove
Subotica Union oh my god no that's
racist yes I did I think so Daniel does
some light reading in a cave and he can
speak their language fluently I mean
maybe I'm not a linguist I'm just an
asshole but that seems highly improbable
to me
this is symbol for this planet Daniel
can only discover something when it's
unintentionally revealed to him almost
at the last second I found it now is not
the time for the pronoun game give me my
thing this went guy showed up to show
all the slaves that their religion is
bullshit
hey they ripped off the Washington
Monument twice well he sure mastered
that otherworldly alien gun in a hurry
didn't he rather did this ancient
Egyptian asshole get fighter jets I
don't want the bomb to go to earth just
as much as the next guy but why hasn't
he done that already there is literally
nothing stopping him sick sick eyes so
whenever you're ready I guess I'm gonna
stay here make sure this goes off movie
inspires Bruce Willis character and
Armageddon and arguably the entire movie
Armageddon itself you got seven minutes
now he's needlessly put a time limit on
their success which is why you my friend
or a dick
yeah let's point the enemy's weapon at
the nuclear bomb seems like a good idea
and I stopped caring sorry I just I mean
my care meter tops out when it tops out
not up to me and this movie didn't do
enough to oh look I even stopped caring
about this sin about me not caring
I'm not sad I have good news the timer
isn't moving
you've been amused up until now it's
convenient that ross darth sidious
method of killing provides cinematic
suspense while also a lot in time for
the person's rescue all the other slaves
ex machina
let's hope whatever atmosphere this
planet has protects everyone from the
fallout this would probably be really
inspirational if I had any idea what he
said mister leave me behind is going
back now even though he's sort of
developed a nice father-son relationship
with Rufio here I'm gonna be alright
Daniel doesn't go on to say my
intelligence makes me like a god to them
and the most attractive woman on this
planet is super into me I'm going to do
a lot better here than I was doing on
earth I'll be seeing you around
definitely not
I'm glad you asked that because I wanted
to take this time to explain my evil
plan they should have said
my station last 24 hours have seen some
extraordinary Soviet naval activity